As we discussed in
the previous video,
Netflix was willing
to pay over $1 million
for the best user
rating algorithm, which
shows how critical the
recommendation system is
to their business.
In this video, we'll discuss
how recommendation systems work.
Let's start by thinking
about the data.
When predicting user ratings,
what data could be useful?
There are two main types
of data that we could use.
The first is that for every
movie in Netflix's database,
we have a ranking from all users
who have ranked that movie.
The second is that we know
facts about the movie itself--
the actors in the
movie, the director,
the genre classifications
of the movie,
the year it was
released, et cetera.
As an example, suppose we
have the following user
ratings for four
users and four movies.
Our users are Amy,
Bob, Carl, and Dan.
And our movies are Men in
Black, Apollo 13, Top Gun,
and Terminator.
The ratings are on a one to five
scale, where one is the lowest
rating and five is
the highest rating.
The blank entries mean that the
user has not rated the movie.
We could suggest to Carl
that he watch Men in Black.
Since Amy rated it highly,
she gave it a rating of five.
And Amy and Carl seem
to have similar ratings
for the other movies.
This technique of using
other user's ratings
to make predictions is called
collaborative filtering.
Note that we're not
using any information
about the movie itself
here, just the similarity
between users.
Instead, we could
use movie information
to predict user ratings.
We saw on the table that
Amy liked Men in Black.
She gave it a rating of five.
We know that this movie was
directed by Barry Sonnenfeld,
is classified in the genres
of action, adventure, sci-fi,
and comedy, and it
stars actor Will Smith.
Based on this information,
we could make recommendations
to Amy.
We could recommend
to Amy another movie
by the same director, Berry
Sonnenfeld's movie, Get Shorty.
We can instead
recommend the movie
Jurassic Park, which
is also classified
in the genres of action,
adventure, and sci-fi.
Or we could recommend to
Amy another movie starring
Will Smith-- Hitch.
Note that we're not using
the ratings of other users
at all here, just
information about the movie.
This technique is called
content filtering.
There are strengths
and weaknesses
to both types of
recommendation systems.
Collaborative filtering
can accurately
suggest complex items
without understanding
the nature of the items.
It didn't matter at
all that our items were
movies in the collaborative
filtering example.
We were just comparing
user ratings.
However, this requires a
lot of data about the user
to make accurate
recommendations.
Also, when there are
millions of items,
it needs a lot of
computing power
to compute the
user similarities.
On the other hand,
content filtering
requires very little
data to get started.
But the major weakness
of content filtering
is that it can be
limited in scope.
You're recommending
similar things
to what the user
has already liked.
So the recommendations
are often not surprising
or particularly insightful.
Netflix actually uses what's
called a hybrid recommendation
system.
They use both collaborative
and content filtering.
As an example, consider
a collaborative filtering
approach, where we determine
that Amy and Carl have
similar preferences.
We could then do content
filtering as well,
where we could find that the
movie Terminator, which they
both liked, is classified in
almost the same set of genres
as Starship Troopers.
So then we could recommend
Starship Troopers
to both Amy and Carl, even
though neither of them
have seen it before.
If we were only doing
collaborative filtering,
one of them would have had
to have seen it before.
And if we were only
doing content filtering,
we would only be recommending
to one user at a time.
So by combining the two
methods, the algorithm
can be much more
efficient and accurate.
In the next video, we'll see
how we can do content filtering
by using a method
called clustering.